no one talks about what a value actually is
we see lists of values on the walls of corporations
we hear a lot of kind of lip service being given to how important knowing your values are
but they're never really defined for us in a way that makes them meaningful for my clients
i give a very narrow frame that i'm gonna share with you
that's going to help you know what actually is a core value
and what is a noble value
a noble value is something you aspire to embody as a value
but isn't actually a core value of yours
how do you know the difference how i define it
is a value is something that actually influences your influences your decision making
so you make a decision in a line with your values
you know at your core this is the right decision
when when you're making a decision and you're feeling a little tension or friction
that's a sign that you're actually making a decision outside of your core values
just because you have core values doesn't mean you always act in alignment with them
but this is your check when you make your list of values
look at them and say do i actually decide with these in mind